Good morning, everyone.
I'm Ashley Barrett.
Coming to you with an important update
on behalf
of our greatest hero
and our most loving father.
In the coming months,
Homelander will stand trial
for saving his son
from a vicious starlight loving thug.
An act of heroism.
Now somehow being branded a murder
make no mistake, Vought
and its shareholders stand fully behind
Homelander, and this will in no way
impact his status as captain of the Seven.
We have complete faith
in the American legal system
to get things right, like it always does.
For now,
keep him and Ryan in your thoughts
and in your prayers and be sure to post
with hashtag home free.
So he can see your support.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
They released the New Boys
Season 4 teaser trailer for the promo,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
because Season four will be coming
probably early next year.
Mid-next year.
There's a bunch of stuff happening
right now with the strikes.
And the showrunner
did explained that it would delay
the premiere of season four
just a little bit.
I'll explain that later in the video.
But this is obviously them just joking
about what happened at the end of season
three with Homelander and killing that
dude that threw the can't.
Ryan the big surprise here
is that they're actually going to take
what happened at the end of season three
and they're going to hold Homelander trial
either at some point
at the very beginning of the season
or between season three and season four.
I'm not expecting them
to get too bogged down in this whole trial
for Homelander
at the beginning of season four.
Like they'll get into the main
part of the plot pretty quickly, probably.
Because there's no way that Homelander
would ever let himself be arrested
and be put in prison.
It'd be like trying to arrest Superman.
They had a lot of references to this
during the Man of Steel movie in Batman
v Superman.
With him
addressing the council here. look.
Imagine a version of this with Homelander.
Homelander would just be pretending that
there's no way
that he would bend over backwards
to try and make all these regular people
feel better about themselves.
There'd be, like, a brief hot second
where they tried to put him in cuffs,
and then he'd say, You know what?
I'm done with this. Screw this.
laser.
Everybody in sight.
They even had a teaser for that
in previous seasons
where he almost lost it
on an entire crowd of people
because he got so pissed off at them.
the other part of the joke here is that
Ashley is doing her very best.
Stan Edgar trying to spin
the news towards the benefit of Vought
in general, and Homelander
bravely trying to protect his son, Ryan,
against that vicious Starlight supporter.
all the thoughts and prayers, jokes
and then just the idea
that they're not going
to change anything of their day to day
because of what happened with Homelander.
is a bit of an evolution of what happened
during the events of season
three, where Homelander
just completely lost it on live
broadcast news, but it wound up making him
way more appealing to his base and way
less appealing to just a general audience
they've had this runner during the boys
seasons about the approval ratings
that each of the different superheroes
have, like the higher
the approval ratings
that they have amongst the public,
the more money
they earn from endorsements,
from the products
that they try to sell. Basically.
which is the way that Homelander sort
of measured how much people loved him.
And that's what he wanted. Like
he wanted people to love him.
so he's always obsessed with his quote
unquote, poll numbers in the public.
And that's what happened
after his big rant earning season three.
that spun into
an evolution of the whole idea
that he can do anything that he wants.
But now he actually kind of starts
to believe it
previously,
the idea that he was just kind of saying
that to himself,
I don't think he actually believed it.
He was slowly going crazier and crazier,
but now he's into like
full blown crazy territory
trying to drink his own Kool-Aid.
they also made
it seem like he had this weird moon
night thing going on where he had
this completely alternate persona
that he developed as a child to help him
survive just because of what it was like
growing up inside that special room,
quote unquote, that they kept him in.
remember when we got put in the bad room?
I got us through that.
there were a couple of the promos
that they've released
recently tying in with
this whole Homelander goes to prison arc
that they're trying to tie up
pretty quickly.
Hey there, coal miners, Cameron here.
By now, you've probably heard the news
about Homelander, and he's standing
trial
for murdering a man outside of a tower.
So in all my years as a journalist,
I have never and I mean, never
had to report on anything
so shamelessly fake.
I mean, he was protecting his son
from a malicious attacker,
one of those star later thugs.
And you want to blame him
for defending himself?
Are we still living in America?
Unbelievable.
So now it's our patriotic duty
to help him stay hashtag home free.
And you can believe that
BNN will be following this story nonstop
with hard hitting, totally unbiased
coverage of this ridiculous witch hunt.
It's the least we can do
for our greatest hero
coming out.
I think the idea here is that if
they're only going to do eight episodes,
how many episodes is this trial thing
going to cover, if any episodes at all?
in how is this going to affect
the whole Ryan story arc?
Because that's the real story here.
Like, what's going to happen
to Ryan on all this?
Because it seemed like
he also started to drink the Kool-Aid
towards the end of the season two,
because all he really wants
is to have a loving family in the crazy
smile that he has at the end,
like it seems really dark, like, oh, no,
something's happened.
Ryan's turning dark is meant to be a play
on the idea that kids
will bend over backwards to achieve
whatever it is that they want.
Like he wants desperately
to have this loving family.
so his mind is doing
these mental gymnastics,
trying to make the situation, but
like bending over backwards metaphorically
to make it seem like
this is actually a good situation.
And he's in a loving family
with Homelander,
even though clearly as the audience
you're watching, you're going, No, no, no,
this is terrible. Get him out of there.
The problem with that is that Butcher
is the person that's trying to save him,
and Butcher is almost
just as bad as Homelander.
He's just toxic
in a completely different direction.
so because of the way that Vought
Homelander actually spin things spin
the news in front of Ryan,
Ryan is having a hard time
believing what's actually true.
so it's not like Butcher
can just walk into the room
and tell him all these bad things
that Homelander has done.
And Ryan will immediately believe it
and leave with him.
I don't want to call it brainwashing,
but it's kind of like the Todd phenomenon.
Like Todd loves Homelander so much
that he'll just believe anything
that he says
and anything bad that happens to him.
He'll immediately believe that somebody
has some conspiracy to play this.
Trying to discredit Homelander.
So I think the idea that they're trying
to keep Ryan from going full blown Todd
during season four, season five beyond,
however if you want to be more hopeful
about the ending
of the ultimate boys season,
whatever that winds up being like season
five, that ends up being the last season
it'll ultimately be about Ryan
realizing that on is it like
oh you're a terrible person I need to stop
this and it's Ryan versus Homelander
sort of like Superboy versus Superman
because the whole idea is that
Homelander is meant to be so powerful
that almost nobody can stop him.
Like they barely stopped him during season
three with Soldier Boy Hughie and butcher
all on the compound.
Be and because of the way
that Ryan got powers biologically
being born with powers,
the idea that he could potentially become
just as powerful as homelander
also I think the idea is that if
anybody came after him, like anybody else
randomly had powers, came after Homelander
Homelander would try to stop them.
if he was confronted with a fight
with his own son, like Homelander
would refuse to kill his son, allowing
Ryan the chance to actually kill him
there was a brief moment like that at
the end of season three with Soldier Boy.
When Soldier Boy realized
that Homelander was actually his son.
Like you Stopper's like,
okay, let's
actually try to be a family together
briefly
until he obviously went
in a completely different direction,
the minute he threatened the thing that
Homelander wanted most to be a family.
That's when Homelander turned against him.
if you heard about the season four delay,
that was the showrunner
saying that he wouldn't actually
premiere season four, they wouldn't allow
season four to be premiered until well
after the writers strike is done.
So there's a lot of work
they have left to do on season four that
they just paused because of the strike
my guess is right now, just based on
the way things are playing out,
they won't be able to premiere the season
before spring of next year, but I think
a lot of people weren't expecting it
to premiere until 2024 anyway.
They confirmed that Jeffrey Dean Morgan
is going to be playing a new character,
so they're just slowly accumulating
more and more supernatural cameos.
Well, and the questions
I think that we're asking
now in in in real life,
I think the boys in particular
does a really great job
of kind of paralleling what's going on
in the world this episode.
You know, they talk about everyone
having cameras Now,
All they have to do is get Jared Padalecki
to cameo during season five.
you can let me know in the comments
who you would want him to cameo as most of
the characters that they're introducing
on the show in successive seasons
are still people from the comics,
but there aren't that many comics,
so some of the characters
they just create on the fly.
the other big narrative
that's going to be happening in season
four is the whole battle
over the White House.
Like who is going
to control the White House
because even though it seems
that there are a couple
of different forces on the show
that are trying to control
the White House,
ultimately it's really just about Vought
trying to control the White House.
if you think about it
this way, the whole idea is that Victoria
Neuman wants to win the vice presidency
on Robert Singer's ticket.
She was vying for all this power,
making all these deals, backstabbing
people, betraying people.
She betrayed Stan Edgar.
she threatened to kill Starlight
if she didn't help her toe.
The party line
and help her win more political power.
Anyway, though it seems like she hates
Homelander and hates Vought.
Like everything the board is doing
the whole idea is that Stan Edgar's long
term plan was to control the White House,
and he was grooming her.
To be able to eventually do that.
the whole idea is that
he was behind everything
Victoria knew him
was doing the whole time.
and even when she betrayed him,
he seemed bemused by it like, Aha,
the student has finally become the master.
She's done
exactly what I trained her to do.
so it still seems like even now Victoria
Neuman is still doing what Stan Edgar
wanted her to do fulfilling his dream
of controlling the White House.
If you remember, way back in season two,
they sort of teased this was Robert
Singer's character
when he was talking to her
about literally telling the president
what he was supposed to be doing, like,
wait a minute,
you want to control the White House?
Yes, absolutely.
I want to control the White House.
back then, it was about them starting
to get compound V in the military.
Then by season three, he'd reveal
his real long term plan is to basically
get rid of their superhero business,
like basically get rid of the Disney
side of their company,
like the extremely evil version of Disney
that was just fronting compound
vs superhero so they can make more money.
Like we got this formula
that can turn people into superheroes.
How can we best monetize this?
Well, let's create some fake superheroes.
it'd be like if Disney had the ability
to create real superheroes
and they built the Marvel brand around
that just as a way to make money.
But then he revealed during season three
that that was actually kind
of a lost cause.
They could make more money just by being a
core pharmaceutical company,
like an even more evil version of Pfizer.
so ultimately, he was planning on getting
rid of all their superhero business
and just selling the temporary compound
to the military and making way
more money with way
less downside way less collateral damage.
They actually teased that during season
one that was superheroes cause more damage
then they prevent
and one of the other biggest cliffhangers
that they didn't address
at the end of the season
was what's going to happen to Butcher,
because it sounds like
he only has a couple of months to live.
the only way around
that is if they find a compound.
The superhero whose powers
are literally healing that kind of damage.
That would be like an easy workaround.
So I'm not expecting it to happen
any time soon.
Like there'll be some other way
that they end. His story arc.
We'll be getting more promos like this
for the rest of the year.
We probably won't get like a really big
Season four trailer until early next year,
maybe like at the very end of this year.
post all your theories about
where are they going to take season four
and season five.
Beyond that.
Right now, we're also in the middle
of Marvel's Secret Invasion episodes.
My full episode 4 video we'll post
next week after they release it. So
be sure to enable alerts for my channels
so you don't miss all that.
Click here for that episode 4 video and
click here for that new Deadpool 3
First
Look and learn about all the crazy cameos
that are happening during the movie.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!